[Music]
in the southeast of berlin in atlas off
the helmholtz centre berlin operates
besi2 a particle accelerator
which produces extremely bright x-ray
light
besi2 is the only german synchrotron
radiation source
that generates this so-called soft x-ray
light
which is why researchers from all over
the world come to berlin
for their studies at helmholtz center
one of them is dr tristan pt who uses
bessie 2 for his prize winning studies
on new materials for storing electrical
energy
so i'm working on a new class of
materiel
called maxine which are very interesting
for
new type of energy storage system
and especially i'm using the singletron
basic2 to try to understand how
energy can be stored in such materials
but how does the particle accelerator
work messy 2 is both an x-ray microscope
and a slow-motion camera in the middle
you can see the so-called synchrotron
that accelerates electrons to almost the
speed of light
on the outside is the electron storage
ring with recurring magnetic zones
when the electrons pass through these
the x-ray flashes needed for research
are created we use this x-rays either
to analyze the chemistry of a material
or the structure of such materials and
for that
there are different techniques available
which are sitting
around this big ring where we are
measuring
a few times per year my my research is
basically
an example of what we can do uh with the
light that comes out from bc
and how we can use it to understand
problems that are relevant for many year
users from all around the world are
coming to measure
in my case i usually work through
collaboration so
i have collaborators who send me samples
and we analyze
their samples with the techniques we are
developing here
round about 2 000 scientists like
tristan pt
come to bessie 2 each year at the
various beam lines in the experimental
hall
they can do their research using the
brilliant light the particle accelerator
offers
so the use of this x-ray makes the
methods very particular
for example in my case i will looking
with battery materials which may have a
lot of different
elements and using x-ray we can look at
each of these
elements separately and analyze for
example only oxygen atoms only
titanium atoms and this cell is not
possible
with other techniques than x-ray
spectroscopy
with the help of bessie 2 dr pt is
researching the new material group
maxines
they can store and deliver large amounts
of electrical energy extremely quickly
and therefore might play an important
role in future energy storage
especially in the context of renewable
energy
we want to see inside this particular
chemical reaction happening during
charging and discharging like in a
battery small battery system so this is
very challenging because we have to
probe the different atoms and we also
have to focus x-ray of a very tiny
uh amount i mean very tiny space
so especially this particular few
microns and using
x-ray microscopy we can focus the x-ray
over
a few tenths of nanometer which is
extremely small so the biggest challenge
is as
is combining this uh x-ray microscopy
techniques which have not been done
for liquid measurement into a cell
which simulates a real battery
environment
and this has to be done in liquid
and these two walls of x-ray microscopy
which works in vacuum
and of a battery which works in an
electrolyte so which can be
water or another type of electrolyte
is very challenging and hasn't been done
so much
so what i hope is that thanks to my
research we may understand better how
this model could be a game changer in
the battery world
and hopefully in 10 years from now there
would be
such new materials in every battery that
we have around
and i would hope that my techniques
contributed a little
to this development
on november 2nd ingu miller from the
helmholtz center in berlin will
virtually present
the particle accelerator in german
afterwards there will be a q a session